new couple alert or just friends Justin
Bieber was all smiles on a morning hike
with Sophia Richie Sophia of course is
the daughter of singer Lionel Richie for
older sis is Nicole Richie Biebs was
noticeably happy during the outing in LA
showing off his tattoos in a tank top
and blue shorts meanwhile the 17 year
old model wore her blond hair and a bun
and was stylish rocking an oversized tee
leggings and high-top sneakers but
that's not the only place they are
hanging out Sofia later snapchat it from
Japan where JB has two shows this
weekend as part of his purpose tour yep
that's Justin right there do your
parents let the guys that you go out
with are they strict um they're strict
when it comes to like curfew like your
life's not changing because you have a
boyfriend in March Sophia opened up to
et about her then-boyfriend
but most signs of him appear to have
been wiped clean from her Instagram your
sister is married and has kids is that
something you see in your future one day
yeah for sure way in the future way in
the future but one day around Riverside